so I have the function G here it's
expressed as a fourth degree polynomial
and I want to think about the intervals
over which G is either concave upwards
or concave downwards and let's just
remind ourselves what these things look
like
so concave concave upwards is a is an
interval you're an interval where you're
concave upwards is an interval over
which the slope is increasing and it
tends to look like an upward-opening you
like that and you can see here that the
slope over here is negative and then as
x increases it becomes less negative it
actually approaches zero it becomes zero
then it crosses zero becomes slightly
positive more positive even more
positive so you can see the slope is
constantly increasing and if you think
about it in terms of derivatives it
means that your first derivative is
increasing over that interval and in
order for your first derivative to be
increasing over that interval your
second derivative F prime prime of X
actually let me write it as G because
we're using G in this example in order
for your first derivative to be
increasing your let me write this so G
so concave upward means that your first
derivative increasing increasing which
means which means that your second
derivative is greater than zero and
concave downward is the opposite concave
downward downward is an interval or
you're going to be concave downward over
an interval when your slope is
decreasing so G prime of X is decreasing
or we can say that our second derivative
our second derivative is less than zero
and once again I could draw it on this
so when X is lower we have a look we
have a or it looks like we have a
positive slope then it becomes less
positive and then it becomes less
positive approaching zero becomes zero
then it becomes negative and then even
more negative and then
even more negative so as you see our
slope is constantly decreasing as x
increases here so in order to think
about the intervals where G is either
concave upward or concave downward what
we need to do is let's find the second
derivative of G and then let's think
about the points at which the second
over the second where the second
derivative can go from being from going
from being positive to negative or
negative to positive and that those will
be places where it's either undefined or
where the second derivative is equal to
zero and then let's see what's happening
in the interval between and then we'll
know what over what intervals are we
concave upward or concave downward so
let's do that
so let's first let's take the first
derivative G prime of X it's going to
apply the power rule a lot 4 times
negative 1 is negative 4x to the 3rd
power plus okay you're going to have 2
times 6 is plus 12x to the first power
just write it as X and then minus 2 I
could say minus 2x to the zeroth power
but that's just -2 and then the
derivative of negative 3 of a constant
is just 0 and now I can take the second
derivative G prime prime of X is going
to be equal to 3 times negative 4 is
negative 12x squared decrement the
exponent plus 12 and so let's see where
could this be undefined well the second
derivative is just a quadratic
expression here which would be defined
for any X so it's not going to be
undefined anywhere so interesting points
where we could transition from going
from a negative to a positive or
positive to a negative second derivative
is where this thing could be equal to 0
so let's figure that out so let's figure
out where negative 12x plus 12 could be
equal to 0 see we could subtract 12 from
both sides and we get negative 12x
squared is equal to negative 12 divide
both sides by negative 12 you get x
squared is equal to 1 or take or X could
be equal to the plus or minus or X could
be equal to the plus or minus square
root of 1 which is of course just 1 so
at this the second derivative at plus or
minus 1 is equal to 0 so either between
plus or minus 1 or on either side of
them we are going to be
we could be concave upward or concave
downward so let's let's let's think
about this and to think about this I'm
going to make a number line let me find
it a nice nice soothing color here
alright that's a nice soothing color and
let's say actually make the number on a
little bit bigger so there we go
let's utilize the screen space and so if
this is 0 this is negative 1 this is
negative 2 this is positive 1 this is
positive 2 we know that at x equals
negative 1 and x equals 1 our second
derivative is equal to 0 so let's think
about what's happening in between those
places to see if our second derivative
is positive or negative and from that
we'll be able to say where it's concave
upward or concave downward so on this
first interval right over here so this
is the interval from this is the
interval where where we're going from
negative infinity to negative 1 well
let's just try a value in that interval
to see whether our second derivative is
positive or negative and let's see an
easy value there could be negative 2
it's in that interval so let's take G
prime prime of negative 2 which is equal
to negative 12 times 4 because negative
2 squared is positive 4 so it's negative
48 plus 12 so it's equal to negative 36
the important thing to realize then is
well if over here it's negative that
over this whole interval because it's
not crossing through 0 or it's not
discontinuous at any of these points
that's why we pick this interval that
over this whole interval G prime prime
of X is less than 0 which means that
over this interval we are concave
downwards so concave concave downward
concave downward now let's go to the
interval between negative 1 and 1 so
this is the open interval between
negative 1 and 1 and let's try a value
there well let's just try 0 will be easy
to compute G prime prime of 0
well when X is zero this is zero so it's
just going to be equal to 12 the
important thing to realize is our second
derivative here is greater than zero so
we are concave upward concave upward on
this interval between negative 1 and 1
and then finally let's look at let's
look at the interval where X is greater
than 1 so this is the interval from 1 to
infinity if we want to view it that way
and let's just try to value let's try G
prime prime of 2 because that's in the
interval and G prime prime of 2 is going
to be the same thing as G prime prime of
negative 2 because whether you have a
negative 2 or positive 2 you squares
could becomes 4 so you're going to 4
times negative 12 which is negative 48
plus 12 which is negative 36 which is
negative 36 and so once again on this
interval you are concave concave
downward now let's graph this ahead of
time let's see if what we just
established is actually consistent with
what the graph actually looks like we
were able to come up with these these
insights about the concavity without
graphing it but now it's kind of
satisfying to take a look at a graph and
actually let me see if I can match up
the interval so actually this is pretty
closely matched right over here and so
this is actually make it a little bit
smaller all right and so let me move my
bounding box so I'm saying that I'm
concave downward between negative
infinity negative infinity all the way
until all the way until negative 1 all
the way until this point right over here
so all the way until that point and that
looks right it looks like the slope is
constantly decreasing all the way until
we get to x equals negative 1 and then
the slope starts increasing the slope
starts increasing from there from there
all the way and right at X we're
transitioning so I'm going to leave a
little I won't color in that and so here
our slope is increasing doing that same
color our slope is increasing
increasing increasing increasing
increasing all the way until we get to x
equals one and then our slope starts
decreasing again and we get back into
concave downwards oops I want to do that
in that orange color we get back into
concave downwards so what we were able
to figure out by just taking the
derivatives and doing a little algebra
we can see quite clearly looking at the
graph